um so when you you uh danny reimer at
index did your seed yep
uh you had greylock congratulations to
your series a
yeah uh kleiner perkins moon um formerly
of social capital
did the b but sequoia passed on the b
you said yeah well actually greylock
passed in the seat too
so we have a history of uh of firms that
passed us then all right back there so
they
passed and they said hey listen what was
the reason let's go through this
what was the objection that greylock
gave you when they passed on the seed
and then how does one as a founder
take that no and turn it to a yes 24
months later yep or 36 months
yeah so basically the person i talked
with at greylock was john lily
who going back to our earlier
conversation was the ceo of mozilla
for a long time and so i deep respect
for him very technical
uh loves design kind of like the perfect
person to
join us and um uh stuck with a bunch of
firms for the seed
one of them was uh index and they called
us that night and we're like we're in
cool that's awesome was that like a
quick 500 million dollar check or
something uh well we raised they did two
million of a four million dollar round
okay wow uh so it was it was awesome and
they were they've been incredible
partners entire way through i mean like
they've been awesome um but another firm
we talked with uh
was grillock and john lloyd in
particular and uh john
john was like very transparent i mean
he's like a very direct guy
and he's like look like and and to be
clear he was correct uh
he said there's a lot of compassion but
he was like i really like you guys
like what you're doing i think there
could be something here but like
i don't think you know what you're doing
yet you're not qualified
and and to be fair like we totally
didn't agree um
and not just from like a like business
standpoint which i mean we're all
learning all the time but also from like
a strategic standpoint
yeah like we just didn't have the right
strategy at that point and so
then kind of went to the point of like
okay we'll just keep talking
and he made clear that he was down to
and so we kept having coffees every
month or two
wow um and he would give us advice and
just was can you give us connections he
introduces people that were
really helpful that's nice and so how i
can be helpful
is kind of the way people make fun of
vcs uh-huh
in john lily's case of greylock he
actually did that
he didn't have skin in the game and he
was helpful and he was just helpful
generally awesome and helpful
so people hate venture capitalists in
silicon valley
because they think that how can i be
helpful is like
uh pandering nonsense or whatever
when in fact it is your first hand
experience i mean
i think most investors i've met in
silicon valley and this is a biased
experience for sure and
i'll say everyone shares this but uh
have
genuinely be helpful and like also they
i think like the investor sort of
personality type often
yeah is definitely one that's much more
nurturing and like yeah wants people to
succeed like that's kind of like you
don't i don't think
you make it long as investor if you
don't have that person no you have to be
of service
yeah and it's like you're joining
service you're like aggressive like
shark tank person or ever like that's
not the thing that actually happens
no sure this is why i like when they i i
got
pitched on shark tank when it was
dragon's den and they were just bringing
it here
and when they pitched me on it and i was
potentially going to be on it in that
first season
i mean i i did two calls with them and
then i didn't wind up on it
which made sense because i didn't have
any successful investments at the time
and i i said to him i said you realize
that this like negotiation
because i watched the dragons and stuff
i was like that's not actually how it
happens like
you're not trying to diminish the person
and make them feel bad
so you can get a better deal you're kind
of doing the opposite you're trying to
build them up
knowing they're going to storm the beach
and the likelihood is
failure and they're going to get their
head blown off and this company's going
to zero
so you're kind of sending them off to
this crazy war
knowing so you want to get them pumped
up to storm the beach
there's also an incentive for investors
of like you don't know when the next
company is like right the next amazing
company next uber whatever is right in
front of you
and so you don't want to piss someone
off
that like exactly i want the chance to
like leave the next round or ever yeah
if you were a jerk
to travis during scour or red swoosh
you may have missed uber yeah uh
or if you were a jerk to elon at x
or zip2 maybe you don't get tesla and
spacex or boring company
but i've also like just had very few
experiences where investors are jerk
like most of them have been awesome to
me yeah um but he going back to john and
he was
at some point after a lot of coffees he
said look like if you ever think about
raising a series and someone we're still
in stealth mode by the way like wow
we hadn't yet launched anything had no
customers
but we had started like a very small
alpha and he's like if you guys
um think about raising an a let me know
a few weeks later i called him up and
was like hey like think about raising
reason a
i want to work with you we did talk with
a few other firms but like
it was i basically just wanted to work
with john if you know the other firms
that said yes
yeah i don't know if i would have gone
with them it's a good lesson for
investors you know like
be of service be as helpful as you can
and as naval told me
when we were both starting off maybe 10
11 12 years ago
maybe 10 or 11 years ago we both started
to do angel investing
and he said jason the reason we're
winning
is because we're in a competition to see
who can be the most helpful
and the three most helpful people right
now three or four most helpful people
are paul graham you me and
uh ron conway huh and we're the ones who
go talk to founders
and write small checks that's the race
to be the most helpful and i'm going to
start this angel list thing i'm taking
my my venture hacks
blog and i'm going to make it a website
like facebook or linkedin for angel
investing and i was like wow that's cool
totally crazy